my name is Michael Norton I work for a
large global engineering company
designing infrastructure projects around
the world and the question that I'm
going to answer is the world around
youth and it is this is youth
participation important for the economic
development of Latin America and how
should your people get involved this is
a really good question because youth of
uthan from the 21st century a generation
y century this is a very different from
the ones which we've seen in the past
generation x a native of boomers and I
think that big companies like the
company that I work for and government
organizations really need to understand
what it is that motivates generation of
my vehicle because it's different and I
think that unless companies and
governments really understand how to
motivate reward and continuously
challenge Generation Y people they're
not going to realize the full potential
of using